we are living in an age of unprecedented
technological advancements each day
rapid progress is being made in fields
that have the potential of transforming
our lives forever as a futurist my job
is to look ahead and spot these key
trends so let's explore 10 of the most
mind-blowing emerging technologies
poised to change and transform our
business and society in the coming
decades artificial intelligence and
robotics the holy grail of ai research
has always been general ai this
all-encompassing hive mind is self-aware
and commands intelligence equal to a
person's although scientists are still a
few years away from an ai like that we
have had tremendous success with narrow
ais those have already started to have a
significant impact on our world for
example narrow ai is already being used
daily to power systems like spam filters
google maps and virtual assistants such
as siri humanity has also successfully
managed to pair ai with robotics another
field that has seen a boom in
development over the last decade as
scientists progress with sensors and
actuated technologies we can create ever
more realistic and practical robots to
perform human tasks these robots with ai
are being used in various settings such
as manufacturing healthcare and retail
with technologies like fully
self-driving cars and humanoid robots on
the horizon this decade will be crucial
for ai and robotics technologies with
the right investments these technologies
have the potential to change our world
in ways we can't even imagine
5g and internet of things or iot this
may not sound very mind-blowing to you
still the next generation of cellular
network technology or 5g for short has
the potential to revolutionize the world
the difference between 4g which most of
us currently use and 5g will be
exponential 5g networks may ultimately
be 100 times faster than 4g allowing
many more devices to connect reducing
latency to practically zero and
providing more reliable signals combine
that with the internet of things and the
possibilities are limitless iot is a
term used for anything that takes the
internet beyond our computers iot will
be the keystone technology for
futuristic settings such as smart cities
robot driven agriculture and
self-driving highway systems and 5g is
expected to be the connectivity backbone
of that future one of the biggest
bottlenecks of the current iot system is
bandwidth and latency a 5g network
solves both the problems so with proper
implementation iot has the potential to
flourish once 5g becomes ubiquitous
allowing us to live in a totally
connected world where physical and
digital systems are seamlessly
integrated with the internet satellite
constellations a few years ago elon musk
spacex launched the first batch of 60
satellites as part of their starlink
project today there is a constellation
of over 2 000 satellites already up in
the low earth orbit with a plan of
inserting 40 to 50 000 more in the
coming years this may sound like a crazy
idea but it's not without its merits
currently the internet travels through
undersea optical fiber cables that
criss-cross the world's oceans and you
can find out more about that in this
video i did about it unfortunately this
leads to many transmission
inefficiencies as delivery is reliant on
physical wires this is also why it is
impossible to provide every square inch
of the planet with internet connectivity
there are various spots on the earth
currently where you cannot get internet
access satellite constellations are an
ideal solution to these two problems
imagine a giant canopy of satellites
covering the entirety of earth beaming
down the internet even in the remotest
of places this universal access to the
internet will have profound effects on
our society especially in the developing
world as information becomes readily
available
self-healing concrete
shifting to the world of construction
self-healing concrete is an emerging
technology that has the potential to
totally alter the way we build
infrastructure this new type of concrete
can automatically repair itself when
cracks appear the key ingredient of this
special concrete is yeast when mixed
with regular cement the yeast goes into
a dormant state however once the
concrete cracks and water seeps in the
yeast becomes active again and produces
calcium carbonate this process fills up
the gaps and prevents further damage
this is a massive development as it
would mean that roads buildings and
other concrete structures will be able
to last much longer without the need for
constant maintenance making our building
safer and allowing us to save a lot of
time and effort that can be redirected
towards other developments the
technology is currently in its
developmental stages but it might soon
become a standard construction material
worldwide
graphene graphene is a material that has
often been hailed as the wonder material
of the 21st century and for a good
reason too graphene is an allotrope of
carbon meaning it's made up of only
carbon atoms but unlike other allotropes
such as charcoal or diamond graphene is
a single layer of carbon atoms arranged
in a hexagonal lattice this makes it the
thinnest material in the world but don't
be fooled by its delicate appearance
graphene is considered the world's
thinnest strongest and most conductive
material for electricity and heat it is
also one of the lightest and most
flexible materials ever discovered all
these properties make it a very
attractive material for several
industries with potential applications
in electronics energy storage and
construction since its discovery in 2004
graphene has been the subject of intense
research with many different
applications being developed currently
these applications include water
filtration desalination ultra fast
charging batteries heat sinks for
electronic devices aerospace materials
wearables and even artificial muscles
the scope of graphene based products is
virtually limitless and scientists have
only just begun to scratch the surface
floating farms the world's population is
projected to reach 9 billion by 2050
this means that we'll need to produce 70
more foods than we do today just to keep
up with demand but as our population
continues to grow the amount of arable
land per person is shrinking this
presents a real challenge for feeding
the world's growing population in the
future but one potential solution to
this problem is the concept of floating
farms floating farms are a type of
agriculture conducted on platforms or
barges that float on water this type of
farming has several advantages over
traditional methods it doesn't require
large tracts of land for starters which
is increasingly becoming a scarce
resource it also allows farmers to take
advantage of otherwise unused space such
as lakes reservoirs and oceans in
addition floating farms are less
susceptible to drought and can even
purify water by filtering out pollutants
the concept of floating farms is still
in its infancy still if successful it
can forever change the way that humans
farm and solve the global food crisis
hydrogen fuel cells hydrogen fuel cells
are a type of energy storage device that
converts the chemical energy of hydrogen
into electricity one of the main
advantages of hydrogen fuel cells is
that they're highly efficient and energy
dense in fact they're twice as efficient
as an internal combustion engine running
on fossil fuels in addition the
byproduct of a hydrogen fuel cell is
essentially water instead of toxic gases
making them a very environmentally
friendly option in comparison hydrogen
fuel cells are significantly more
efficient than their ev counterparts
because they are free from the
constraints of lithium-ion batteries
industry experts believe that hydrogen
fuel cells could be used to power
everything from cars and trucks to homes
and businesses in the future this will
have a significant impact on reducing
greenhouse emissions and fulfilling
global decarbonization goals blockchain
by blockchain i don't mean
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin but the
technology behind these currencies
blockchain has become one of the most
exciting technologies in recent years
because of its potential to
revolutionize several industries
blockchain is a distributed database
that allows for secure transparent and
tamper-proof transactions at its core
unlike traditional centralized records a
blockchain is decentralized the
permanent record is not stored in one
location but exists on nodes spread
across the system this makes it an ideal
platform for many applications such as
smart contracts supply chain management
voting systems banking and healthcare
the list is literally endless the fact
that blockchain is still in its early
stages means that the full extent of its
potential is still unknown but as
technology continues to develop we will
begin to see it having a profound impact
on how we live and work natural language
processing natural language processing
is a branch of artificial intelligence
that deals with the interaction between
computers and humans using natural
language nlp is used to build
applications that can understand human
language and respond in a natural way
for humans if this sounds easy it is not
we humans can use language easily
because our brains are adjusted by
millions of years of evolution but it is
challenging to teach a computer how to
hold a fluent conversation recognizing
gestures context and cultural cues all
things that we humans use to express
meaning and ideas nlp is still in its
early days but it has come a long way in
recent years currently one of the most
exciting applications of nlp is chat
bots chat bots are computer programs
that mimic human conversation they are
commonly used to simulate a human's
conversation in online customer service
in the future nlp will become
increasingly important as humans rely
more and more on artificial intelligence
to help them with their day-to-day tasks
quantum computing quantum computing is
the exploitation of collective
properties of quantum states such as
superposition and entanglement to
perform computation in simple terms
quantum computing can solve problems
faster and more accurately than even
modern supercomputers if you're still
confused check out the video i did on
google's latest quantum computer
achievement while this technology is
still in its nascent stages we can
expect quantum computing to be the
backbone of most of the emerging
technologies of the future first it
could make big data more manageable it
could cut costly and complex development
times of various new technologies
through speedy simulations finally it
may make impossible to solve problems
manageable such as those faced in ai or
natural language processing the
potential implications of quantum
computing are mind-boggling with the
ability to solve complex problems that
classical computers can't it has the
potential to revolutionize almost every
industry from healthcare and finance to
cybersecurity and logistics for more
awesome content click a card on your
screen and i'll see you in the next
video